it's different our
our version of that let's say our
version of propaganda is is a little
different from that
it's more it's more insipid and it's
more
it tends to understand like i said it
tends to be more subversive
rather than directly offensive in in the
sense that
it's better to instead of
it's better to show like the show in
versions and to to to to have stories
with
the notion that the inverted is becomes
the
norm in a way and that seems to be the
way to that that a lot of
propaganda is happening now um and so
it's it's a bit different and so
sometimes it's tricky because sometimes
the stories actually end up looking very
much
like ancient traditional stories it's
often just that they're upside down or
that there's a like shrek is a great
example
shrek is like the most the easiest
example to see
where it looks like a fairy tale but
it's actually an upside down
it's a totally upside down fairy tale
where
you have an ogre ogre and a princess you
know the ogre is this monster and they
they present them as a monster and so
that would be an example of a postmodern
film yeah of an
upside-down fairy tale of a subversive
use of traditional tropes where all the
tropes are there but they're just
totally upside down you know the ogre is
represented as a monster
he suggested it suggests that he's a
cannibal he suggests all these things
that the normal
ogre is and then he meets a princess and
in the end the princess becomes an ogre
and it's like okay the shape of water is
a great example too recent more recent
version
where all the normative characters you
know the
the christian the the the the the white
male
all that they're all absolutely evil
okay and uh
and then all the kind of exceptional
characters like the monster
and then all these other exceptional
categories are somehow pure and innocent
and all of that
and then in the end the the woman
becomes becomes a monster like that's
how it ends she goes into the water she
becomes a sea monster
and it's like we're so used to it we
think that somehow that that's a normal
way
for a story to go but it's very
disturbing you know
a normal i've seen that so much in the
past 15 years yeah and a normal story
like the story of the frog and the
princess for example is that
the exceptional character the frog this
talking frog who's a monster
is by some proof of their virtue
integrated into the world right little
mermaid becomes a human
yeah well that's a difficult thing
becomes a human yeah ponyo is a yeah
that's
that's a good that's a good example